You know, I'm fascinated by this because for years
you played a doctor, like for a long time.
For a minute, yeah.
Well, seven years, that's a long time.
That's a minute, yeah, it's been a while.
And you play a doctor and you've switched now.
You're still the same character.
Yes.
But you've moved on and changed your role.
To a firefighter.
You're a doctor that became a firefighter.
Which happens all the time.
It does happen all the time.
Because of that pay kick up.
Yeah, I'm tired of saving lives.
Anyway, so here's my question.
I've heard of some other people who play doctors
that they start to sort of develop the characteristics
of a doctor, if you do it for long enough,
and the confidence of a doctor,
and then when people see you on TV playing a doctor,
they kind of, there's sort of a sense of like,
oh yeah, he could kind of do it if he had to do it.
People assume that you actually know what you're doing.
Yeah.
Which is a huge mistake, don't ever do that.
Right.
Yeah, I mean, I was actually on a plane one time
and the thing that occasionally happens,
you hope it never does, but you know,
somebody started having a medical issue on the plane.
Right.
And so the message went out,
is there a doctor on the plane.
And the funny part was, there's a little part of me
that was like, who's gonna look at me.
Yeah.
(audience laughter)
Who's gonna look at me?
Right.
And it didn't happen.
And I was a little disappointed.
Yeah.
I mean, if I'm being honest, and they, you know,
they got the issue rectified, they found a real doctor,
and you know, we went on the flight, we landed,
we got off the plane, and--
Person was okay.
The person was okay, everybody lived.
And then I'm walking through the airport
and I came across the flight attendants.
And they walked up and they were like, "Hey, we're off
the plane now, so I just want you the know,
I love Gray's Anatomy, I love the new show,
can I get a photo?
Oh by the way, I almost got you for the medical thing."
(laughter)
I felt better about myself in that moment.
I think there was some part of you
that would wanna get involved, you know what I mean?
You'd wanna get up there
and just do some chest compressions.
You wanna jump in.
I can perform CPR with the best of 'em.
I'll pound your chest all day long.
What the--
Yeah, okay, all right.
(laughter)